et pourtant malgré toutes ces
affirmations
on vient de déclarer aujourd'hui on ne
meurt pas de faim au cambodge
ce sont les termes mêmes exact employés
aujourd'hui par le ministre cambodgien
des affaires étrangères dans une
interview à un quotidien japonais
il ajoute deux millions de cambodgiens
sont menacés quand même par la famine du
fait des séquelles de la politique des
khmers rouges
le précédent régime mais la situation ne
correspond nullement aux exagérations
mal intentionnés de l'occident fin de
citation
alors on peut se demander si on ne rêve
pas en regardant les images que vous
avez vu au début de ce journal en
écoutant les témoignages de ceux qui
sont sortis du pays des responsables de
la croix-rouge des nations unies qui ont
pu se rendre sur place et puis aussi en
regardant encore ces documents qu'a
rassemblé pour vous edwards
ils sont depuis 24 heures plusieurs
dizaines de milliers à avoir franchi la
frontière qui sépare le cambodge de son
voisin
la thaïlande plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'hommes et de femmes qui
viennent grossir les quelques deux cent
mille réfugiés massés dans ces camps à
la recherche de nourriture de
médicaments ou tout simplement d'un
espoir de survie ici donc c'est la
thaïlande est le plus souvent à
l'arrivée ne fût ce qu'un bol de riz de
l'autre côté
derrière la frontière le cambodge avec
ce que l'on en sait par quelques
témoignages des récits tragiques
tellement tragique qu'ils en deviennent
presque incroyable des récits qui en
fait
tiennent en deux mots la famine et la
mort
en
la situation du pays est bien est encore
faut bien le dire beaucoup plus
préoccupante ultramatic que ce que l'on
pouvait prévoir
d'après les récits de réfugiés et les
autres la formation qui ont verts qui
avaient filtré
la chose qui frappe le plus lorsqu'on
arrive au camp kucera et la pression des
peuplements de selon les estimations
gouvernementales
il y aurait aujourd'hui camion d'un
cambodgiens vivent enfin ce qui
représente approximativement la moitié
de la population de ce pays il ya
quelques années
le reste est bien le reste a tout
simplement disparu
pas le fait d'un bombardement a fait de
guerre parfaite
le massage ou de famine ou de maladie il
est impossible de savoir quelle est la
part respective gars ces différents
facteurs
certaines provinces comme la province la
libérienne la province de travail sont
pratiquement désertique
on voit personne pourquoi est-ce que
voulez vous cacher le visage non parce
que je n'aime pas pour manger encore des
parents qui sont encore aucun bouc et
aussi surtout mes enfants qu'ils sont
encore là bas je pensais avoir des
représailles des chantages des groupes
qui n'ont pas contents de nous de
l'héroïsme et rouge
est-ce que vous avez des nouvelles de
votre famille mais jusqu'à présent mais
j'ignore complètement
c'est par où ils sont j'ai essayé de
maintenant de padt était partout des
services que gère april
vous avez des enfants alors l'avant nous
avons trois quatre enfants dont quatre
enfants trois filles et en carton et
comment se fait-il que vous ayez été
séparés de mai c'est le régime qui ce
n'est pas nous sommes pas les seuls à
l'origine comme le régime khmer rouge
origine frères ou les enfants qui ont
entre 6 à partir de 6 ans sont
obligatoirement séparer de la famille un
cambodge à peine sorti de 30 années de
guerre qui bascule en 75 avec les khmers
rouges dans un génocide sans pitié qui
bascule en janvier 79 avec
l'intervention des vietnamiens sous une
autre coupe étrangères
les vietnamiens qui s'empresse de
justifier au monde entier leur
intervention pour cause humanitaire
dénonçant les atrocités du régime
précédent
aujourd'hui ce sont les vietnamiens qui
gouverne et occupe le cambodge avec
l'impossibilité où la volonté de ne pas
pouvoir nous ne pas vouloir sortir ce
pays du cauchemar avec peut-être
l'objectif de faire renaître cette
vieille idée c'était le testament de chi
minh d'une fédération indochinoise dont
les maîtres serait bien entendu les
vietnamiens mais qui leur impose la
disparition pure et simple du cambodge
que les journalistes étrangers soit
autorisée en convoi a visité la région
des temples d'angkor pour les
vietnamiens celle à prouver qu'ils
n'entendent pas toucher au symbole de la
civilisation khmère
mais pour le reste il n'y a évidemment
aucune explication officielle
le reste c'est tout simplement la
disparition d'un peuple tout entier
les glaces qui ont subi les pertes les
plus sévères sont évidemment en premier
lieu les intellectuels la plus grand
partie des médias ont disparu
il enlevait approximativement 500 il ya
quelques années il y a
la 56 qui sont connus beaux jours les
professeurs également on constate la
même chose des juristes ont pratiquement
tous disparu bref on a l'impression que
tout cela classe la plus cultivée de ce
pays
elle va une jeune pays avec un niveau
d'éducation élevé à grands pas t-il
cette classe cultivée a disparu et
jusqu'à présent dans les conditions
fantastic les autorités du cambodge se
sont absolument refuser à permettre un
accès direct à ceux qui meurent à ceux
qui meurent sept enfants dont venaient
de voir une photo il n'existe plus il y
en a plus de son âge
python de polpot on se disait un monde
et voilà que les vrais responsables
maintenant au cambodge sont les
vietnamiens les hommes que nous avons
admiré dans leur combat des hommes
qu'elles étaient responsables de leur
front bas et eux aussi contribuer à ce
que ces populations soit emmurée vivante
meurt lentement derrière des murs
étanches cambodge devenu aujourd'hui un
pion sur l'échiquier politique de deux
grandes puissances la chine et l'union
soviétique
mais ce sont une fois de plus les hommes
les femmes les enfants qui meurent
victimes de cette effroyable et caton
les 8 millions d'habitants que comptait
le cambodge il y à peine deux ans il
n'en reste que quatre millions la moitié
4 millions des composés par les maladies
par la famille incapable physiquement
trop faible de débarquer les secours qui
commencent à arriver à phnom penh et
avec ces chiffres terribles des femmes à
la dernière extrémité qui avortent
spontanément la disparition pratiquement
totale de tous les enfants de moins de
cinq ans et pour les derniers survivants
savoir simplement que ce sont des morts
en sursis